oggi uscita la religione si chiama
dragon ball fighters questi sono soldi
ben spesi ma edizione qui e non parte
registrazione questi sono soldi ben
spesi soldi e da piccolo giocavo solo a
giochi
non so come come er non ne ho idea certo
goku grazie di presentare i personaggi
perché non li conosco ma devi far vedere
tutta se non mi interessasse una sega di
quello che sto vedendo prove bene posso
giocare un po benvenuto questa sala
d'attesa si celi personaggio d'attesa
goku super saiyan piccolo bull ma faccio
bull ma in sala d'attesa bene anche il
design eco lo posso ragazzi io sono
quella sinistra scegliamo gli verrebbe
da scegliere goku come base infatti
scegliere quello facciamo gol contro
anno che si sa dove scegliere due
personaggi dai facciamo dalla goku e
vegeta il classico tra i personaggi
scelgono come je tecnico e non un modo
l'altro lo sceglie a ipad altro computer
randomico bene alziamo goku vegeta e
crilin contro goku vegeta trucks va bene
si pero state calmi lega quanto fatto
bene
bene non so i tasti o sei tasti che a
caso sono forti beccaccia 100 acri li
aiuto stai dove devi stare tu che muore
e basta
ragazzi erano idea di quali siano i
comandi bene così really non e sei stata
proprio la scelta
ok vice progetta picchiare fuori le cose
io non ho idea di come funzioni non ero
io quello sono fortissimo insomma che co
sto facendo bene
dopo andato giù la mani per parte
cattiveria vegeta contro la gente regali
come non detto
io cambio personaggi non sono escono
scotti il cambio perché mi metti grilli
lo capisca come si fanno le mosse
speciali stanno facendo cose incredibili
questo gioco è il sesso i punti mi ha
presentato un fenomeno che viene
attenzione cose a fiato va bene
[Musica]
cioè io compreso
come non detto koch per cortesia ok ma
vegeta ma non ho capito bene come faccio
a cambiare supplicando da tempo a caso
però la qual cosa succederà
probabilmente è un ora che ho sbloccato
la mostra speciale però non so come
farla porsi cavalca ogni tanto mi
stupisco limes tessere l'ultimo pugno
perfetto non ho allora non ho capito
come si fanno onda energetica segue
trovo sicuro di essere mio figlio che il
figo quindi base a chi battiti mette
nelle frasi apposta in due io vegeta era
ok porca vacca contro vergeat acrilici
[Applauso]
[Musica]
kacar 8 perfetto sì però io sto con sei
veramente mi piacerebbe sapere questo
facendo schiacciando trascritti cosa
vedo cose accadono aiuto e l'amato 4 è
modello per quanto difficile battere le
getta super sayan gol come funziona non
so se lo forte 2 grazie veggente lo fa è
stato non ho capito come si fanno le
mostre speciali regali giulio lei
tagliate male mi sono fatto malissimo
sono morto bene non dopo immagina sia la
stessa cosa ma l'ho presa tutta in
faccia se è male puoi fare un'onda
energetica per favore dell'infanzia
eccolo questo voler maledizione che vi
casa questo gioco non ora ci ha messo
per fa sta roba
le cose successe va bene non va bene
questo è stato un incontro difficile
quasi perseguibile quello chiamato ci
dice sa se va bene e va a rega moglie
contro marito siamo arrivati al finale
sto perdendo c'è rischio di perderla
questa regata di impegnarmi troppo
magari se lo sparring faccia lei non
auguro non è male ancora picchia picchia
picchia pelato picchia che l'ato
maledetto donna madonna comitato sta
roba
vai così alla fine ti ha dato una mano
grave dai non mori e basta dai stavolta
potrebbe morire forti sarà uno scontro
interessante amici quello è sì qualcosa
me lo diceva come monito guido io voto
sì ok è convinto anche lui e pelato
l'unica ragazza
vai diminuzione ho avuto un infarto
assist c'è un tasto che fico per
richiedere assistenza dal compagno però
non ho ben capito bene assistenza la
crisi proverei quanto conta però non ha
ben capito quale ho cambiato cambia io
come voce con miei personaggi non so
neanche io guardo lo porti caricare in
faccia al nemico dei problemi come
faccia che non sa anche come sto facendo
per caricarmi il picchio tutto inviati a
quando uno richiede assistenza poi
picchiare quell'assistente quindi di
levi vita fantastico perfetto meglio di
prima
qui caprisa era un catino
vabbè si trova resistenza da goku magari
assistenza da cochi assistenza da gorgo
assist e gol assistenza golf screening
va beh secondo me non è forte thriller
ma per niente lo sarò anche io che
faccio schifo a giocare però mamma mamma
mia quanto di casillas
ti prego ti prego diversa salvami
d'infanzia un'altra volta ma è già
abbattuta una volta sto stronzo di paolo
bravo così così il mio uomo
mamma mia mamma di gesù grilli favola
perfetto soprattutto non so come ma va
bene ne manca uno perfetto lui
che avevo entrato a fatica no no il
grillino crini no ti prego non contro di
lui non contro c16 vi prego madonna come
le prende in faccia
grazie goku e entrato coco ha fatto le
cose meno male a me era caduto sui la
madonna o che abbiamo intel e forza
così ti voglio uomo mamma mia che mi dà
soddisfazione
va bene beh ragazzi siamo riusciti a far
anche terzi in conto niente di meglio
speravo ha finito tutto proprio preso c
quindi quindi io avevo fatto la sa bene
confermato la via dei serpenti bene così
ragazzi direi che va bene così per oggi
ho dato prova di essere però io mi sia
piaciuto ragazzi con cui ho qui
l'episodio di oggi in consensi molto mi
piace sicuramente farò un altro episodio
con un pietro comunque qualcun altro che
gioca con me perché questa volta ho
voluto provare il locale se non avessi
schiette e non ci vediamo
[Musica]